uh the 2022 latin american music awards
are happening right now over at mandalay
bay and jillian lopez takes us on the
red carpet
hey you guys guys we are at the latin
american music awards red carpet right
outside of mandalay bay a lot going on
and i'm joined by the one the only
caesar milan he is presenting tonight
how are you caesar oh you're really good
thank you thank you so much for chatting
with us you know family yes how does it
feel to be out here well you know it's
like we're and we're the same breed
the same breed that's right we're having
a good time you know latinos we
understand each other we have a certain
energy that we grew up with so it's good
to be home yeah you guys are bringing
the fire tonight let's talk about what
you're presenting and how's it gonna
feel to be up there on the stage well on
stage just what i do right is i do live
shows but uh regional mexicana which is
the north of mexico and it's something
that is very rude to my to where i'm
from i'm from the north of mexico
sinaloa mexico so it's perfect it's
perfect you're going to do a great job
you know black eyed peas are opening the
show a lot of great performances coming
back bunny is nominated for like 10
awards a lot happening is there someone
or something you're really excited to
see or someone you're excited to see
perform you know everybody is here
because i earned it they earned the
position but the one i was very excited
about is an older guy his name is el
puma and um i grew up with him you know
what i mean the rest of the guys are
pretty much my kids generation you know
but um you know it takes a lot of work
it takes a lot of faith a lot of you
know uh passion and hard work and that's
why i'm here i love him really quickly
what's next for you what are you working
on these days we're working in few
projects you know season two of a better
human better dog obviously is doing well
podcasts and my kids have a show so you
know it's all in the family keep it in
the pack keeping it in the family well
caesar thank you so much for taking the
time good luck presenting tonight
enjoy your time in las vegas we'll see
you next time
the dog whisperer how fun is that all
right well be sure to tune in to the
latin american music awards a lot going
on i'll send it back to you guys